we begin with dangerous weather on both
sides of the country including a
powerful storm that could dump more than
a foot of snow in parts of the Northeast
the late season Nor'easter is also
expected to bring ice and heavy winds
that may knock out power to thousands of
people in the region Lilia Luciano is
out in the snow in Fitchburg
Massachusetts Lilia good morning
good morning to you Michelle well this
morning I've already met Crews that came
from as far away as Tennessee even
Washington State prepared to restore
power at this hour We're hearing that
there's about 75 000 customers without
power including about 20 000 or more
than twenty thousand in Massachusetts
alone and the wind isn't even expected
to pick up until well into the afternoon
in central Pennsylvania conditions went
from bad to way worse when heavy winds
brought fast snow officials are warning
drivers to beware of slippery roads and
low visibility snow also landed along
the Connecticut Massachusetts state line
the first hint of what's expected to be
the Region's first Northeastern this
late winter season this is an event
where the snow is going to be so much
heavier so please just wait you don't
have to do it the second it Falls New
York Governor Kathy hokel declared a
state of emergency and has already
activated the National Guard warning the
storm could be deadly stay in your homes
it is very very hard to plow the roads
when there are people in front of you or
cars that insisted on venturing out and
end up in a ditch and have to be rescued
according to the National Weather
Service windus could reach 50 miles an
hour from New York City to Boston
we're just west of the City emergency
crews from Pennsylvania pitched in to
trim branches that could snap under the
weight of today's expected heavy wet
snow and take down power lines you can
have snowfall rates that exceed an inch
an inch and half an hour signs of
coastal flooding along Massachusetts
Shore were already evident Monday
while further Inland residents took to
Neighborhood sand piles I'm just filling
up my bucket getting ready for tomorrow
those 20 inches we're getting when you
live in New England if you're not
prepared you're looking for trouble
I mean the rain has been falling at
about an inch an hour starting at
midnight and that's expected to continue
throughout the day it's kind of hard to
see because the flurries are so big and
they just fall in your eyes of course
nobody expects for children to go to
school on a day like this for those who
are unluckier on the start of St
Patrick's week they're doing remote
learning others just having a snow day
Nate
Lilia thank you